bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right chris so you have an
incredible
story um can we start with
where were you and what were you doing
on september 11 2001.
i got to tell you i don't think i have
an incredible story i have a story
and i did my job and that's what the
country expected of me and there are so
many people that did
way more at the end of the day though
the american people paid me to do my job
uh september 11 2001 uh was
one of those days and i think it's it's
interesting you bring that up
because a lot of people the younger
people now don't
recall the like searing experience that
that had for
so many of us i was went for a
it was in the morning and it was a
beautiful
it was a beautiful fall day just one of
those magical days and
uh the non-commissioned officer that i
was
working with sergeant major mel bynum
uh was my partner and we decided to go
for this beautiful run in the morning
and we ran around we were at fort
campbell kentucky we were in the fifth
special forces group which is the
special forces group
that's responsible the special forces
groups are responsible for different
parts of the world
our part of the world was the middle
east and we
we went for a run and it was just
magnificent and it was one of those days
that starts and you're just like this is
going to be a great day
you know thinking about going home early
you know take the kids out
and we got in the car and we were
driving back to work
because we were at an out we were at
this out station called clarksville base
it was just one of those days
and on the radio i was listening to this
really
uh probably inappropriate morning show
it's called the john boy and billy show
it's only in the south right
it was really funny you know at the time
and
all of a sudden the announcer broke in
and said
hey something something's happened and
it wasn't funny you know it's like
something really dramatic has changed in
our lives
we have a report of a plane crashing in
the world trade center and it was
just so striking the tone of voice there
was no joking anymore
you're like okay and as you recall like
back in 1942 i'm making that up some
plane small plane crashed into
the empire state building so the pundits
were like oh maybe it's nothing by the
time we got back to work
and i walked in to our intelligence
section
in the in the unit i was i was in 3rd
battalion 5th special forces group
walk in there and you know how sometimes
history when you look back on things
you're like
did i really experience that or did my
mind create that after the fact
well and so i thought about this a lot i
walked in they had the tv on
and we saw the second plane go into the
building and i always have to think back
i'm like did you really see that or have
you just seen it happen
so many times i was so that happened
i was like is that live and everybody
goes that's live
i said okay our world's just changed at
that moment
and uh it was funny
well it wasn't funny that's a horrible
word to say
we just we knew that some we were going
to go to war i don't know why
and i was called i was a company
commander which is a major which is
i was responsible for six 12-man a-teams
and there were men at the time now thank
goodness there are women
in them uh biggest biggest
change we should have done 20 years ago
but that's neither here or there
thank goodness but at the time they were
12 men a teams and the 12-man special
forces a team consist of
two medics two engineers
two communications experts two weapons
experts
two senior non-commissioned officers
that handle operations and intelligence
and then two
officers so i was in charge of six of
those and what i had was called a that's
an a team i had a b
team which is a headquarters element of
you know about 10 people
so we're like wow something just changed
i got called over to the battalion
headquarters battalion headquarters i'm
there's
a team company commander battalion so
battalion has
three companies each company has six aid
teams
so in the battalion they're 18 a teams
we went into the battalion commander's
office
and what i really recall was this hey
there's nothing to see here
you know things happen in the world all
the time just dial it down a notch
that's that's what i that's what i heard
i'm like uh no
the world fundamentally changed and here
was the crazy thing and this is the
genius of special forces that
i don't think i really appreciated at
the time we left that meeting
and i walked over to the company i
commanded it was this all
crappy world war it wasn't world war ii
it's vietnam era building was just
nasty and we had this long haul and i
walked in
and every a-team was
had pulled all their equipment out of
their wall lockers and had lined it up
in the hallway and everybody's going
through checking their equipment
checking batteries
making sure things are maintained making
sure nothing's broken
and i was like okay game on they knew
so our a teams were like they knew we're
going to war
and they're like what's up sir and i'm
like keep going we're going to war
but that was not the instructions i was
given from my higher headquarters
at that time but we all knew the game
was on and we were going to be
a critical part of that we knew it was
been live and everybody don't
jump ahead of yourself this is an
al-qaeda we're like yeah it is
so chris when you think about um kind of
the days
after september 11th there was a whole
bunch in the public sphere
of you know what happened uh who did it
why
um and kind of a crash course if you
will on extremism
uh especially on the religious front in
the middle east and kind of why there
would be such deep hatred for
america and the american ideals what was
transpiring
at the highest levels of our military
over those days so on september 11
specifically it was dial it down
you know this isn't a big deal but at
some point between that and
you know i think early december of 2001
uh we end up
training and uh invading afghanistan and
so kind of how do we get from
the response up on september 11th uh
which was maybe a little bit more
lackadaisical
to actually going to afghanistan thanks
anthony
and so it was so interesting i was like
an eyewitness to history i i call it
like the fly in the wall like i don't
know why i
experienced all this uh serendipity fate
karma i really don't know what it is and
as the things developed you've read in
the books now that there was a camp
david meeting like right after the 11th
where i think
uh who was director george tenet i think
was director of the cia at the time
and there was this meeting with
president bush where they're like
tenants like we're going to get this on
and uh the other guy kopher black was
the head of counter terrorism
legendary guy let the flies walk over
their eyeballs or something i forgot the
you know he had this great line that
still resonates
i just remember so i didn't know that
meeting happened
i was instructed by our group commander
group a team company battalion
group group has three battalions of
you know three companies of six a teams
i know it's confusing as hack
but that's that's the big deal and at
the time it was a guy named
legendary guy colonel john mulholland he
retired as a lieutenant general just
absolutely legendary figure that i've
just like been a mentor to me is like
oh my gosh he's like my second father i
can't say enough good about him
i'd worked with then colonel mulholland
prior
and he goes chris go down
to the united states central command
that's the that's
centcom that's the that's the military
organization that's responsible for the
middle east
and go down there and uh his
instructions were get us in the fight
and i was like i know how that means
mission type order that's pretty good
went down there left on the 16th of
september the reason i remember that
date is it's my anniversary
and usually my wife would be extremely
upset with me for taking off on our
anniversary and this is the one time
she's like get the hell out of here
it was really and and that's when i knew
it was serious you know i knew it was
serious
thousands of americans were killed but
i'm like wow
who went down there and here was what i
learned
anthony and people will now say oh
that's revisionist history i'm just
going to try to relate to you what i
experienced at the time
i was a green beret i was a special
forces officer
the the purpose of united states army
special forces green berets
is to conduct unconventional warfare
unconventional warfare
is when small teams 12-man teams or
smaller
go behind enemy lines into a hostile
region
a nation state that's controlled by a
hostile regime in this case the taliban
you go behind enemy lines you link up
with resistance forces insurgents
guerrillas and then you we
green berets will provide them training
advice support air support logistics
support and help
them take back their country from the
reigning uh
ruling regime so you know
i've been in special forces at that
point 2001 i
went in special forces in 93 do the math
i'm not going to do public math
and just hold down
and uh went in there and we're like this
is what the regiment was created to do
the re special forces regiment the green
berets had never
truly conducted an unconventional
warfare campaign the reason special
forces in unconventional warfare
if you recall world war ii and you
recall occupied france
and small commando elements dropped in
before d-day
and worked with mckee and the uh the
resistance forces and brought them
together
and help them and communicate that's
kind of what our thing was
and then after world war ii there were
these visionary people
uh that aaron bank and some others
that father of special forces said we
can't get rid of this because the soviet
union
is going to invade western europe so
we're going to have these green berets
they're going to stay behind or they're
going to jump behind enemy lines
and then we're going to have this this
inflame flames are going to build in the
rear of the soviets and we're going to
you know
take them out from behind so that was
that's kind of the classic
unconventional warfare that's what
special forces green berets were created
to do
and we'd never really done it some
people will say oh we kind of did it
here and there like we never did it
so p i'm going to get hate mail now oh
actually
chris and 1982 and pakistan you know
whatever i'm just saying that we really
hadn't done it and so going down there
is like
we know what to do this is this is
tailor-made for unconventional
warfare here's the thing the military
doesn't always like the weirdos special
operators because they kind of like they
don't wear uniforms all the time they
grow their hair long
facial hair stuff that the big military
typically doesn't like
and the big military was like we have a
plan
what we're going to do is we're going to
go invade the country and this is how
we're going to do it
we have all these forces in europe tanks
you know bradley fighting vehicles tons
of infantrymen artillery men
and what we're going to do is we're
going to put them on trains we're going
to move them down to uzbekistan
we're going to mass combat power through
the winter
and when the spring because you know the
mountains you know all this stuff you
brought up like we didn't know a lot
about it we we'd heard you read
red rudyard kipling and watched you know
movies were like this is going to be
really bad so the military the large
military was like
very conventional approach and they were
going to come down there and build
combat power and then in the spring they
do this big you know tanks coming across
bridges and floating
you know crossing rivers and stuff and
and and helicopters flying in and all
this stuff
and we're like yeah we don't have time
for that
and so it was one of those moments where
the senior leadership was desperate for
solutions
and i think the cia had come up with
some ideas too like i
noted earlier in their meeting at camp
david with
president bush so it this was my
interpretation
and i was there by the way was
oh crap we need some ideas to secretary
rumsfeld like
yesterday anybody have them and all of a
sudden
those of us that were green berets it
was like hey
are there any green berets here like
yeah you forgot about us here we are
we're just sitting here drinking coffee
we got the call and they're like we need
a concept yesterday
we'd already had it done this guy uh bob
kelly there was just some
remarkable remarkable people down there
and it i think it became okay well we
got to do something
yeah let the green berets go do their
thing let them mess around
and then they'll kind of prepare for
when the major military forces move in
and then when the spring offensive comes
they can they can help with that
so that that was my recollection and
it's right on how that thing went down
and so chris when you think about the
actual uh kind of initial invasion
uh for those who've watched the movie 12
strong uh it's from my understanding
uh pretty accurate in the sense that we
literally dropped off a couple of
americans
and when they did their thing and so
when you're
seeing that uh kind of in preparation
and then it actually starts to happen
talk a little bit about just the
uncertainty and the unknown and
especially when uh you're in a position
more of kind of commanding control
in the position of leadership and you're
sending you know what is uh
deemed to be the uh the most physically
fit
uh kind of our best war fighters into
this situation but fully understanding
you know we haven't done this before
right and uh
and there's gonna be a lot of things
that we're gonna about to learn and and
the people on the ground are gonna have
to uh
use the training that they have and
frankly just their intuition to uh
to survive and thrive in this
environment so kind of as it's actually
transpiring what's going through your
head or what are the memories that you
have
uh kind of being in that leadership
position i just remember
a couple a couple things boy not sleep
well tonight after this
oh no i just remember like general
colonel mulholland at the time he's a
colonel
that's like that's like mid-level
management right
and here he is in charge
of the most significant
military operation in modern history
and he's the one who's making the
decision i'm not making the decisions
about who's going into harm's way
and when they do it and how they do it
he is i'm just
i'm just the spring but if you will like
hey we need to go faster
and i i don't even know why he still
talks to me because i was such a
difficult young person at the time how
old were you by the way chris at the
time uh 30 let's see
don't do public math i was born in 65 so
what was i
36 ish at the time and
here's the thing the brilliance of the
special forces regiment the green berets
it's not the officers
it's these incredible non-commissioned
officers non-commissioned officers
versus a commission officer commissioned
officer
is commissioned by this by congress
usually has a college degree the problem
with special forces
is you know three-quarters of your
non-commissioned officers
all have more better degrees than you
have because they're just
incredibly capable and self-starters and
they're like
well i'm going to get my college degree
and i'm going to get my masters while
i'm at it
so it's it kind of puts the thing in the
head
of the military where the hierarchy the
power is with the non-commissioned
officers the experts and i got to tell
you at the time we went into afghanistan
it was a really rare time
and you brought up 12 strong that team
was
uh led by mark nooch mark newch great
guy he's a captain right he's got like
six years in the army he's
the new guy bob pennington is the next
guy
who is his warrant officers second in
command
bob had been in he'd been an nco
he'd been then i've worn offs this dude
had forgotten more about special forces
than mark mooch ever knew
mark's going to kill me when he hears me
and then i'm just kidding
and then you had 10 ncos that were had
been
the team sergeant the head guy
had been on that team for 15 years
he had been a team sergeant probably for
four years
these folks had most of them had been in
somalia or had been in desert storm in
1991
but they'd had 10 years where there was
no money
you didn't get to do anything and these
guys were
hyper creative hyper creative and these
guys
decided it's brilliant they're like hey
what are the two things that we can't do
in two weeks to prepare you can't do
language proficiency
and you can't do physical fitness so all
they did was study language
in this case we studied the wrong one by
the way although russian helped in some
ways but you know pashtun they're only a
handful
of people that spoke posh too so you had
this
you had this core of enormously talented
uh experienced people and it doesn't
exist right now and that's not a
criticism of the regiment because we've
been at war for 19 years and we have
we've had cycle more and people get
injured and killed but it was a really
rare moment in the history of the
special forces regiment of the green
brace
so it's like you guys go you figure it
out
and colonel mulholland was brilliant he
would do the risk assessment right
and so he was he was constantly dealing
with washington dc
but down and then you just trust your
people you're like hey so
colonel mulholland's key task was to
determine he had a great partner from
the cia
what groups should we support because
there's everybody coming to the table
like hey why don't you come help us
you don't want it we didn't want to
embarrass the united states by
supporting
some horrible person you can argue
whether we got it right or not it was
kind of kind of busy at the time so
that was the key thing was figuring out
who that was
and then then it's it's an act of faith
you know colonel mulholland would give
them a launch order and they would get
on the back
and of helicopters and fly through these
colonel mulholland tells a great story
he was under unbelievable pressure to
get in get in get in
it's like the weather's not right the
weather's not right as they were flying
through the hindu kush
and these helicopters were at max
capacity right
like they're they're redlining they're
on the absolutely outside of the
envelope for their performance
and he was colonel mulholland i don't
know how he did a superhero to me he was
getting pressure from
secretary run fell and probably from the
west wing as well i get going and he
held his line the parameters
are this we will not violate the
parameters he told me later that
secretary rumsfeld
came in for a visit after things had
calmed down
they flew him on one of the routes
where literally walls of the helicopters
or i'm sorry the walls of the
the valleys are literally five feet from
the rotor blades and then
it was like you get it now you
understand why i was holding off so that
was the thing
you talked about physical fitness so
you're going in there you don't know how
long you're going to be there
and green berets always over prepare
the problem is that ends up being you
carry everything in your back
you have what's called a rucksack a
backpack you're putting 150 pounds in
there
and then you have to move so here the
guys came up with this crazy idea
they're like
hey those john deere gators that we see
them driving around at range control so
like sure why not
so we cleaned out clarksville tennessee
of every uh gator
vehicle and what they did because it was
really small
they could put it back in the back of
the helicopter and then they piled all
their crap
in there so they're very light they're
just in their combat equipment so they
can move and fight
and following behind is you know the the
junior guy
who is the new guy he's driving the
gator you know
which was another example of innovation
right nobody
that's not in a manual like hey we got
an idea we called it a mobile mission
support site
usually you pile all your stuff up and
you leave it there and then you can come
back and they're like we can't we don't
know where we're going
so they created a mobile uh mission
support site using uh john deere gators
it was
crazy so that's how they afforded kept
their fitness up because when you're
carrying 150 pound
rucksack it crushes you i mean it
physically
mentally destroys you and your
combat ineffective after oh six hours
can you can you talk about i'm
fascinated by what it takes that you
just mentioned physically to prepare for
a mission like that
but how do you get trained mentally like
how how can you prepare
for uncertainty and not knowing
what's going to happen at all well first
off these morons and i say that with the
with great love uh our next level
they're always looking the green berets
are always looking to improve their
performance so before it was
cool to you know read self-actualization
books
and and think about mental performance
thinks fast and slow or whatever that
book is
i'm going to read that i started it but
man that's a long book
i got through the i got through this uh
introduction you know the one i'm
talking about oh i know
they're always talking about and that's
like what makes special forces special
and we came to the decision you know
it's not equipment
it's not um it's not
um it's not always training
but it's always looking for the next
edge so we
they'd identified that way before it was
cool like mental performance is critical
but here's how it starts it's pretty
brutal it starts with like i want to be
a green beret because
i don't want to be uh i want to have
some
autonomy i want to have some authority i
want to have some creativity so i want
to leave
a big military that doesn't always
embrace it not sometimes it does but
typically not
and then they see like these you know
green berets
that you know get to drive wear civilian
clothes and drive civilian cars
uh and not have to get yelled at for
and have to pick up cigarette butts in
the courtyard etc what the military
typically does a lot of times
so these people volunteer and they go to
this thing
called special forces assessment and
selection it's a three-week
rube goldberg insanity
where you go in there and you've been
brought up in the military where you're
told
what to do every single moment of the
day you will be at this place at six
o'clock
zero six hundred you'll be in this
uniform you'll do exactly this you'll
walk in formation
and then you end up with this at this
fort camp mccall at fort bragg
you show up there they tell you you will
have
these are the required items items these
are the things you can't bring
and then you show up there and you dump
all your stuff out and the
sergeant looks at it make sure you have
everything and here's the crazy thing
you can like i took like two cartons of
cigarettes
and because it wasn't on the you it
wasn't on the list of things you can't
take so i don't know
cigarettes because in in these training
events cigarettes are worth food you
know it's kind of like
oh jail time so the the guys like
the nco was like huh i haven't seen that
you smoke a lot and i'm like
nope starting now and he just started
laughing he goes well
usually people try to stop smoking here
i haven't seen that and right there you
know like i'm in a weird place right the
guy actually
laughed so you're down there and
all everybody wants detailed
instructions
they have a board and they're like what
do we do sergeant what are we doing
tomorrow take your instructions from the
board there's a board
and i'll say zero six hundred
this uniform 35 pound rucksack you're
like ooh
okay no other instructions than that
you show up at 0-600 you got your
uniform you've got your 35-pound
rucksack and this
in sergeant gets up and goes the next
selection event
is you will move under your own power
over land for a set distance
you're like okay what else how long we
going how fast are we supposed to go
because there's always standards in the
army like you all do at this
and you're kind of shocked and you're
waiting so of course somebody's like
sergeant how how how far are we going
a set distance like what the heck did we
get into
then hey sergeant how much time do we
have do the best you can
so it always became read the board
move over land and do the best you can
so that takes that people some people
would collapse because they're like i
don't know what i'm supposed to do
but the people that thrive in
environments where it's
uh where it is flexible and
and not predictable uh just thrive there
and so that's that's how they break it
out is just
you're put in this situation where if
you're not an independent operator
you will you will either fail or
you'll self-select and drop out and so
people
are just constantly dropping out and the
good people great people they're like i
can't do this i mean this is
this is ridiculous i need somebody to
tell me what the hell they do every day
which is fine we need that in the army
too so that's really how
that's the indoctrination and then you
go through a year-long training program
where once you're through that and it's
really a gut check at the end of the day
it's like they're looking for people
that won't
quit and you get a point in those things
where you just become
angry and you're like
i'm not gonna quit i'll die first you
hear navy seal teams in
hell week you know i love watching the
discovery channel where they do the hell
week thing
and i love listening to the instructors
when they go
yep we know almost to the hour when the
last person will quit
and then at that point you know we've
broken them all down
and at that point these people are gonna
quit the only way they're gonna they're
not gonna quit
they're gonna be disabled permanently
disabled or they're gonna die
and at that point i love that part with
the seal teams where they go and now
we're gonna rebuild them
we're gonna build them in our image and
the same thing happens in special forces
assessment and selection you hit a point
where you're like you're just so doggone
angry
you're like hello then i'm not quitting
i don't care they could do anything to
me i will not quit
that's what you want in a green beret
and so chris when you think about
kind of the team dynamics and
communication specifically right if you
if you really think of what makes these
great teams is each
individual person uh has a certain
amount of strength both physically and
mentally
they can shoot move and communicate at
you know a
very very high level of proficiency but
also they have great ability to work
within a team and so it's not just about
the individual strength it's actually
their ability
and their cohesiveness with the rest of
the team and some of that is
they may be naturally good at it but
also there's just the constant
repetition and practice and
and um kind of training that goes into
it uh but then you actually
actually add another level of complexity
which is you have a team on the ground
and that team on the ground is probably
better equipped than most on a
battlefield
both with the physical gear that they
have but also all of the support whether
it's air support
medical support uh and then also kind of
the command and control that they can
communicate with and so
how did you think about the idea of you
know at the absolute atomic level of the
individual soldier
we have the best of the best on the
ground and then when they're together on
a team we need them to be able to work
together but then also we need them to
be able to communicate with people who
are not there on the ground
and be able to do that effectively so
that we can help them and so when you
get through those multiple level
levels of complexity are there certain
lessons that you've learned over the
years or takeaways that you have that
you say look whether it's
you know on the battlefield or inside a
corporation or if you're the founder of
a company
like these are the things that you
learned from a leadership perspective to
uh to kind of
integrate across those uh different
perspectives
wow that's a that's a heck of a question
that's that's a big one
i'll take it by chunks i'll try to take
it by chunks
uh every situation is different you know
that's the key thing
like here's where i love to go and this
is why i love special forces
hyper decentralized trust your people
give them broad mission type guidance
give them a left and a right limit
and tell them hey listen i trust you
don't
you can bother me anytime you can come
and ask questions any time you want
but but you you're smarter than i am
just go do it
and this is the end state we want and
they'll
they'll create magic and you know i
could sit there and i could come up with
my plan
and think well you know i'm a college
graduate i've got a master's degree and
i'm pretty you know i got this and they
if you just give them some leeway
and just tell them which direction to go
and trust them and support them
they'll come up with something 10 times
better but that's not always the case
because sometimes you do need to be
hyper uh micromanage on them
but that would be because every
situation is different there might be a
time where they're based on the
political sensitivities
that you really have to go into the
details i always felt though if you told
them the political sensitivities they
come up with the right answer uh
so assessment and selection
is there's also a week where it's all
about
teamwork and i talked about rube
goldberg i'll give
there you'll show up you've got your
12th p man a team
man at the time like i said now thank
god we have women in there
and there's a jeep old jeep you know
world war ii style jeep
missing a wheel they're like you got to
move this
jeep uh the mission is uh you have to
this jeep is critical it has critical
supplies in it you have to move it back
to the repair facility
and there'll be like there'll be some
polls and stuff
and you're you're the team later now and
you're like what the hell do i do with
this
and but of course there's somebody well
you know i had this problem when i was
in montana when i was growing up
and that's the leadership test is are
you going to tell everybody what to do
or are you going to say guys
what do we do so they'll come up with
this rube goldberg thing and then
it's physical fitness it just kills you
but the thing you learn
too is the teamwork part that you
brought up anthony
who can work in a team who can take like
weird orders
who's willing to step up when somebody's
not feeling well
and then you have this ruthless thing
called the peer review
oh my gosh so you have to vote
1-12 who's the best and who's the worst
and if you're 12
you're probably not going to the next
phase so there's this
ruthless meritocracy and culling process
and
you just don't get to say like oh i
don't like jim he's like why don't you
like jim
jim failed on this event we were down
and out
and he you know he didn't uh he quit
so that's how that works now oh my gosh
high functioning teams i'm just still
amazed still learning learn every day
want to learn more
and i think i really might my
absolute in my essence is like give
people
their freedom and tell them give them
their expectation but
get out of their way uh it's like you
know
the key thing don't do anything illegal
immoral or unethical other than that
everything's up for uh negotiation
so i felt that that was the best thing
but so often it's uncomfortable
when you're in a new situation and maybe
it's a new product
line or you're trying to get into a new
business space
and so your instinct as a boss is like
i'm gonna i'm gonna hold on tighter
the thing you i had a great boss one
time uh
ken tovo who's like no at that point
decentralize
more decentralize until it's
uncomfortable you're like oh
geez um i think that hasn't let me down
but you got to really
you got to be invested in your people
because they will screw up sometimes and
of course in combat that comes down to
people getting injured or killed but
unfortunately that's the way you learn
so
after this mission in afghanistan you
come
home and to me it's so fascinating
because
it's kind of like you watch that movie
you talk to people
and you've done something i'm guessing
because it was a secret of like nobody
knows what you just went through
and you're back how do you feel are you
like
i i can't believe that everybody's just
going about their business and i just
went through this crazy experience wow
you're triggered a memory there what i
found fascinating was when i was in
tampa planning the war for uh or
colonel mulholland uh i went like i told
you i went down there the
september 16th i was there for a couple
weeks i remember going to the mall
i worked i was working like 22 hours a
day
but i had to go pick up my colonel
mulholland was coming in like you're out
of control i need to come down there and
see what the hell you're doing
why are you going to the mall so i went
it was the first time i'd been
quote unquote you know not working
because i was going to pick him up the
airport
and i swung by the mall and people were
in there
uh you know just doing their thing and i
was
really i was like we are fixing drop
the freaking hammer halfway
or halfway around the world and like i
know what's going on i know all the
secrets and i'm like
planes are moving people are moving
we're going to go we're going to really
really do some stuff and americans are
going to be injured and killed and
we're fixing to go to war the most imp
most serious decision
a country takes and that was just
absolutely surrealistic to me
and i remember i went and got ice cream
at this and i was just like
people are eating they're eating ice
cream like holy [ __ ]
that that was more surrealistic for me
than coming home
because coming home uh it was before i
even got the plane coming out of
afghanistan while i flew out of
uzbekistan i flew out of there uh it was
like hey
got something else going on when you get
home like don't plan leave because we're
going into iraq so i had to go back
and start planning for that and getting
ready to go on that so i didn't have a
lot of time when i got home to really
process any of it
so chris when you think about kind of
the american
battlefield today i think that there's
still debate between
unconventional warfare and kind of the
mechanized military and the more
conventional types of uh
combat that we've been engaged in uh in
the past
what's your general take in terms of
should we use technology and
unconventional warfare to fight
every battle is there a place for kind
of the conventional military and
conventional tactics
how do you kind of balance uh those two
different things today
i think we're in a era of strategic
transition
and we don't really obviously china is
the major competitor
you know everybody knows that but what's
that mean for the military
what i experienced you know my last job
was the i was the acting secretary of
defense in charge of that whole thing
uh you can laugh if you want but i was
and
you know we spent 740 billion dollars
and we build these
huge weapon systems i mean world-class
aircraft
carrier crown jewel of the navy 14
billion that's with the b billion
dollars a copy
for a one uh we're going to build
two or three of them typically for
carriers you have 10 to 12 that's a lot
of money
think about the aircraft that we're
building right now it's called the f-35
joint strike fighter i think that's 1.7
trillion that was with a t not a b
trillion dollars the f-35
is the largest military procurement
program
in the history of the world when i heard
that i'm like
come on that can't be true the romans
built
an entire interstate system throughout
europe that is still being used you know
you go to england and you're on the m5
and they're like oh this is the road bed
that the romans built you know 2 000
years ago i'm like
that cost more than adjusted dollars
didn't it they're like no
no i'm like wow the roman roads are
still
here f-35 is not going to be here in
1500 years i mean it's just not going to
be
so i think i think our
primary competitors autocratic
totalitarian regimes
do not fear our conventional power
because they learned in desert storm
and in the last 19 years do not fight
the united states
toe to toe because we will clean your
clock
i mean it's done now winning
winning the military battle of the fight
versus transit transferring that into
strategic
gain like winning uh we have not been
clearly very good at because we haven't
been able to convert military victory
into strategic
uh accomplishment in a long time
so my thing is we need we can't discount
special operations
unconventional warfare they also in the
military call it a regular warfare
that's like information operations
psychological operations back in the day
it's uh it's security force assistance
where you go in and help friendly
countries and try to develop their
infrastructure and their forces
there's also this thing called civil
affairs where these are brilliant
people who uh okay well we're having a
problem in this country in africa and if
we don't get a handle on it we could
have to do large force
employment later which cost a heck of a
lot of money
sent dozen of them down there and they
they
they learn all about the culture and
they find out the needs of the people
and find out where the fault lines and
the fissures are and try to
try to strengthen the uh host nation
government
and connect them with their citizens
for their needs that that to me is where
we are right now
is that's more important tool than to
have large formations because if we
ever ever fight the chinese toe-to-toe
it will be the greatest strategic error
in the history of america and it's
ridiculous
so you brought up here's where i am and
you know i'm probably going to get run
over by some black limousine from
northrop grumman or something because
you know the industry's huge and they
they have
huge vested interest in continuing the
paradigm
i see what's happening with startups
and mid cap companies out in silicon
valley
up in new york a lot of them are just in
small towns right now that are
developing
leveraging artificial intelligence
machine learning
uh you know small uh
you know the application the the maker
mart stuff
uh where we are able to produce stuff uh
individually
and bespoke and then taking that
here's where i am the most important
weapon system that this nation has
is the six inches between our sold our
service members ears
and that is there's not a lot of money
in that
you know like okay yeah uh
so i really really strongly feel that we
have over
bout we've the pendulum's too far
towards the conventional war fighting
stuff
and we need to bring it back where we
recognize the importance of
non-traditional
unconventional irregular asymmetric gray
zone there's a whole
there's a whole liturgy of words that
you can lexicon that you use so that's
where i am and i think
that uh the spirit and the creativity
that hap is happening in america because
remember the old days
it was like the government told industry
what to do
and they did it and we paid him really
well it's on his head now you guys know
that it's on his head
no the creativity is happening in the
commercial sector with startups and
small companies
and so we department defense ashton
carter
ash carter was uh he was the first one
him and uh bob work
was his deputy brilliant guys they're
like uh oh
paradigm shift get with it department of
defense has not embraced it yet it will
but
it takes so long i could ask a million
questions off of that
but um i don't want to get run over by
the black suv
so um you when we started you mentioned
you were just
a guy from from iowa um
how meticulously did you plan
your career in the military and did you
know what you would do when you came
back
no no huh
you know some people you have a great
line on one of your things about
you would go to job interviews and
they're like oh what's your what's your
five year plan
i'm like you i'm like hey doing
something i enjoy
feel like i'm contributing feel like i'm
learning and uh feel like
uh you know paying the bills
so my i have my wife's name on my
computer i'm really chris not kate
that's fine sorry about that my computer
broke yesterday long story uh
so you know it was just like do things
that matter
and learn take care of your family
so i just attributed i never had never
had a plan all i have friends so i
learned this you know i had friends that
would
they had every year marked out i'll be
here just start here and then grab me
i'm going to work for this person
i never did that and i think i saw i
don't know about you all but
i think i saw the people that over
planned boy never worked for him i was
like yeah
the big thing in the military would be i
want to go to this unit
i'm like i go wherever they tell me i
don't care i just go
you know work hard and it sounds it
sounds so cliche right show up
figure out the network figure out the
incentive structure figure out what's
important
and then then exploit and get some work
done
um so i saw a picture of you when you
went to afghanistan and you had the
beard you had the crazy hair
and how do you how do you transition
from being in the field to being in an
office being more strategic
uh and then focused on policy because i
feel like not a lot of people can
transition like that
how did you do it and why did you do it
survival
i you know i did 22 years in quote
unquote the field and field units
and always kind of thought like i'm like
this policy stuff sounds kind of
interesting but
you'd never want to go to washington dc
if you're a field soldier just kind of
one of those things
but ultimately you're going to go to
washington dc my wife loved
likes washington dc so i was at that
point where i'm like i'm not getting a
field assignment those days are over you
know it's like kind of like
okay it was a good run but uh you're now
going to
i have to go learn about the enterprise
that's what they call it
enterprise assignment and ended up in
washington dc in a policy shop
uh not against my will it was another
thing i was told like
you're going you're going to the
assistant secretary of defense for
special operations low intensity
conflict
this is what i knew about the pentagon i
thought
that i was going to work for a secretary
like in
the secretarial pool i mean old school
right i'm like
gonna go work for a secretary i'm like
whatever you know
i had no idea so i thank goodness we had
the internet by that point
i was like i was supposed to be at work
i was actually mowing my lawn when i got
the call
and i got on there and i checked i was
like oh
i had no idea that in the pentagon i
always thought like everybody was just a
uniform person i had no idea there was a
civilian side
office of the secretary of defense
civilian oversight and then you have
the uniformed services the joint staff
and army navy air force marines now
space com
pretty cool uh space force uh
so i had no idea and so i walked in
there
completely complete neophyte going what
did i get myself into but man it was
like fascinating because you
when you're a green beret all you love
learning about new cultures like
that that's a new culture i mean new and
different incentive system
different language i was like hey this
okay
i'm gonna figure this one out so it was
kind of just your
typical got to survive so i have to
figure this one out
and but at that point you're like okay
i'm broken down now and i'm not gonna i
had this dream that i'd retired i gotta
shave my beard
uh my hair dream i was going to go back
and do that when i retired i
retired after 27 years in the in the
service you know kind of got out my own
terms i'm like i'm still healthy
i'm going to go hostage rescue team fbi
i could do that and then i saw this
video one of their
you know hype videos where this truck
this bread truck comes
screaming up to this building and
they're all
these hostage rescue team guys i'm back
on the top of the thing
and they jump onto this roof and at that
point i was like
oh man my my back i had sympathy pain
i'm like
yes those days are done i'm not going to
be carrying a gun anymore that's what i
wanted to do but you also have to and
that's the key thing in the business is
you have to recognize when your day is
done and you need to hand it off to the
next generation
you also have to realize that if you go
on target again
you're putting other people at risk
because you don't want to have your back
go out when you're like
you know humping lugging out a casualty
so
at that point i'm like i think i'm a
policy guy now
so chris uh you eventually kind of rise
to the ranks and become the acting
secretary of defense
uh which is um you know one of the
highest positions of
power and influence within uh the
defense uh kind of sector
just saying yeah and so when you step
into
no joke yeah when you step into that
role what are the things that you're
thinking about
in terms of uh learning kind of the
culture
and the objectives the challenges that
you're facing
and then maybe walk us through like the
first you know 60 90 days like how do
you actually walk into a new role and
and from a kind of execution standpoint
actually
tackle the job without stepping on
everyone's toes but also kind of moving
things forward
so my first job uh the
in in washington dc the coin of the
realm is being a presidentially
appointed senate confirmed official
that's like
that's a big deal you know in dc it
probably doesn't mean anything at home
my parents are like what i don't
understand what you are
but in dc that's a big deal and i was
selected and was confirmed by the senate
to run
be the director of the national
counterterrorism center and a dear
friend of mine chris costa
shout out goes you need to read this
book i'm like oh god i don't know if i
can
he gave me the first 90 days forgot who
wrote it so i gotta read this this is
the book
this is your road map and i had always
been a little skeptical of some of that
stuff because
you know in the in the military they
always say don't do anything for the
first 30 days just learn your
organization
i can never do that i'd be like oh god
no we got to get moving so i decided
learning organism at least i think i am
or try to be
it's like i'm going to implement the
first 90 days so i read the book
and i'm doing my listening tour and i'm
doing all that stuff
you know all the stuff you're supposed
to do it was fascinating there were some
issues it was just i was like this is
gonna be
great you know i'm gonna get the like
place needed to be transformed
unbelievable workforce that was was
ready to go
but wasn't wasn't really being listened
to as much so i'm like this is great and
then of course
uh president trump decides to get rid of
secretary asper mark esper
and there are only a handful of us that
are eligible for the job because we're
senate confirmed we have national
security experience and i get the call
like hey
getting red as for you know you want the
job i'm like well i don't particularly
want the job but it's not you're not
asking me you don't go to the oval
office for
oh no i'm really not interested thanks a
lot i took the king's coin
and you know i'm just going to go ahead
and ah thanks i've got a good gig
you know you're not allowed to do that
you're you're public servant you know
the president asked you to do something
you serve like that what you remember
the west wing i serve with the pleasure
of the president i mean i kind of take
that stuff seriously i'm non-partisan
and kind of uh but you know that's
what you're asked so i go in there and
i'm like i only have 73 days so that
book
the first 90 days not gonna work uh
i'm going to write a book just kidding
uh
hours because in that point you were in
a
transition you're in charge and
it's chaos and but you got you have your
job to do
and you have to a lot of people thought
i was just going to sit around for
73 days and not do anything i'm like oh
hell no
i was the guy who used to complain about
all the morons that were in charge of
the place and now i'm the [ __ ]
and i said there's like that would be
hip critical of me if i went in there
and just didn't do anything because
remember the only things we really
needed to do there were three things
one no military coup two was no major
war
three don't have troops in the street
beating up
americans to argue all day about
how the third one went down but at the
time
i was like i'm not there's more than we
there's more that we want to do so i had
a job
jar going in and uh
draw down the war end the war i want to
end the war i'm sorry i'm done with that
i'm like it's we got to end this thing
we got to move on
gave it a great shot god bless everybody
love them to death but it's time to move
on
uh that was number one number two was i
really felt strongly
and the president did too was the
department of defense needed to do more
71 000 americans die every year from
illicit drugs coming in from south of
the border
and the department of defense was not
doing what i felt was enough
and so that was another thing i thought
that was a national security issue
a lot of people in the department of
defense like no that has nothing to do
with war fighting i'm like
wow 71 000 versus how many people got
killed by terrorism last year 100
i mean tragic for 100 i'm not saying
that but i'm like come on
740 billion dollars a year 1
million people in uniform well actually
it's more than that
one million civilian employees i'm like
we can walk and chew gum at the same
time we can actually commit some
resources south of the border
so that was the other thing i wanted to
do i felt like transforming the
department for competition i felt we
were still stuck in the cold war model
we still
are and i knew i was going to lose but i
was going to be the one who
forced the issue so i moved special
operations low intensity conflict
the civilian people that oversee our
commandos
i moved them out of from underneath they
were like
buried in the bureaucracy i made them a
direct report in the secretary of
defense but that was just a
that was a side hustle because what i
really wanted to do was bring together
information cyber space all these
functional things ai security all these
things that are now like stove-piped
all across the defense i'm like let's
bring them together because those are
the capabilities that we need
to embrace uh so those were the type of
things
and then the mechanism i used i i read
that innovator's dilemma i mean that
book changed my life i know people
probably make fun of it now but
playing christian may rest in rest in
peace i read that book when i was
younger
and i was like okay innovation you know
you have your three models
so the model i used was i basically put
a startup
in the front office that correctly
reported to me
i had about 10 people now they were all
career civil servants they weren't
political appointees because political
appointees are kind of transient right
these are all people i'd worked for and
i trusted and back to your point about
like hey how do you get high functioning
teams moving i was like hey
this is the end state i'll give one
example i told you i was in karshikan
about uzbekistan k2
that place was a toxic waste dump we
didn't know it at the time and a bunch
of
a bunch of veterans and service members
had had medical issues from it so a
brilliant guy
out broadband buddy of mine grew up in
the military he was a civilian lawyer at
the time
in the department of defense it's like i
don't know what's going on go fix it
so we had about eight things that we
wanted to do and but here's the thing we
knew
all of us i've been in the pentagon long
enough i talked about like learning the
culture
i knew how the place worked so the whole
idea was to play it back against him
like i knew how
i knew how the process worked i'm like
okay we're going to exploit the heck out
of this
and i knew that we could move faster
than the bureaucracy could so we just
decided to flood the system
and just get everybody so could
everybody
create chaos uh was what i was doing
so no one could figure out exactly what
our key tasks were there were so many of
them
and then there were ways that you you
could keep pushing on your eight key
issues and no one knew which ones to
resist because
the nature of the frozen middle of any
bureaucracy right is like
everything's fine we don't need to do
anything so
we we would had the frozen bureaucracy
so
confused that we were bypassing and
doing all that so that was the mechanism
i used
uh in the secretary of defense office
okay so when you were uh in the
secretary of defense
office you mentioned uh you were there
for 73 days and a lot
happened uh including the storming of
the capital
is there anything you wish you had done
differently or how do you evaluate it
now looking back i'm hyper
hyper critical of my performance that's
the nature of
being a former special operator is
that's the one thing
you get done with it you never did good
enough
i'm telling you it was amazing growing
up you would have
you'd be like we did everything right
though operation went
perfectly and when you did the after
action review or you did your hot wash
after
the person that led it they would always
find fault you know and
and i love that and they're like you
know what you could have turned
left two seconds earlier and you're like
yeah so i love that and i i embrace that
and so i absolutely did a hot wash and
all that and the story has not been told
and you know that's where i realized
i thought national security was above
partisanship
that's the criticism i have of myself
was i was so
freaking naive i was like
well now i mean at the end of the day
we're all americans and we care about
national security and we're not going to
politicize this
my experience from that was oh my gosh
and that's what we're experiencing right
now the truth has not been told the full
story has not been told
and in my do you mean when you say that
do you mean
uh the whole story has not been told in
terms of how politicized every action is
no how the what has not been told yet
is in the complete narrative
of what happened that day and the
department of defense
i uh have been you know harshly
criticized and ryan mccarthy the
secretary of the army have been
and my wife and others are like wow
what do you what would you have done
differently i'm like you guys don't know
the story yet when the story comes out
i will stand by every decision i made
his direct proper use of the armed
forces
so uh that's not one i'll tell you what
i know when i screw up because i lose
sleep over it and then you have like
some moral guilt
you know we all have that right we all
have that like oh yeah kind of like
i messed that one up but you know maybe
sometimes you're in a situation where
you have to
you know posture and say oh we did it
all right
i have not lost a single moment's sleep
about the decision-making and what the
department of defense did that way
and uh but but it hasn't been told yet
and frankly
you know until congress pulls their you
know what out of there you know what
their head another you know what and has
a honest and i'm not being political
right now yeah yeah
we're not going to know and that's what
i'm seeing right now is like
i i you know i watched the testimony and
i'm like
they're like oh god they're pushing me
under the bus that's fine
but we'll get our say and i think when
it's all said the problem now
with this you know entertainment media
political complex
that is just driving this hyper
partisanship even
further apart just driving wedges into
our country i'm sorry to get so
emotional but i live that you know
when they're attacking your children i
mean come on
give it a break for heaven's sakes we're
still americans
we should still have some respect for
each other and
so unlike when this story's told the
problem is
it's all the narrative's been
established so now you're like page 26
retraction
miller and mccarthy in the army and the
department of defense were not complete
morons that day actually when we looked
at it everything they said was accurate
so it'll come out one day but that was
probably the biggest failure in my part
was this
idea that i was dealing with uh rational
people that
had the best interests of the country at
hand and that
definitively is not the case chris can
you think about it
when you ask when you think of um
you know that incident or others and
it's really interesting because
the people in the story if you will
always have more information
um is it something that you think uh
let's take january 6th or whatever as an
example
there are contextual things that
eventually come out and that changes the
way that people view it
there's specific you know abc thing
happened on that day
um and that's what changes kind of the
the evaluation and i know that you
probably can't share
too much in terms of uh um some of the
the things that aren't public yet but
just
what are the things that you think um
and i'm asking from the perspective of
uh there's a lot of people i think now
understand they have the power of the
internet kind of at their fingertips and
they
uh desire to be kind of independent
thinkers they don't want to just take
the narrative that's fed to them from
uh you know various media outlets and
kind of the mainstream talking points
and so
any advice or kind of breadcrumbs you
can leave them in terms of hey when
you're evaluating a situation like that
here's the things to look for to to be
able to think for yourself rather than
just accept those narratives
well i think you guys are thought
leaders on this and i'm not trying to
you know
give a shout out to you guys but
discussions like this are important
i have a son that's 20 daughter 25 and
27
and they do exactly what you just
described they are so
sickened by the uh the partisan
media and so i asked them like how do
you get your information these days
i think there's a huge business
opportunity everybody's like no there's
not nobody wants it
i'll tell you i have a friend that's
like he just consumes all the political
stuff
and he did for the longest time he goes
i'm just back to watching the evening
news i'm like
why like no that's what our parents did
nobody you know
you can see the ads for the evening news
it's clearly not our
you know demographic he goes nope i just
want somebody to tell me what happened
and all decide but my kids
i mean they don't even follow mainstream
media isn't that amazing to you
the trust is eroding it's destroyed i
mean with my kids
so they're my you know they're my
touchstone that's they're my demographic
for my market research
you know i'm like hey it's your media
these days how do your friends do it
so that's really really critical
uh but when you talk about and so i
think there is a generational issue
going on to tell you the truth
there's a generation in my generation
we're like the last generation that was
born before the internet or some crap
like that right
and we have this fixation and i'll tell
you what it's really funny
i've been in situations where people
we're in we're in
like decision making forum and they're
plugged in on their phone
getting all the updates and
one of my truisms it's i didn't invent
it but you know first reports are
always wrong first
always inaccurate it's time played out
time and again so now you're in a
situation you brought up decision making
in the current
environment information environment
you're getting bombarded with
information
coming from all different directions and
then you have this
huge pressure to make a decision because
everybody's like
weak he's weak she's weak not making a
decision
you know come on didn't you see what's
on cnn right now or fox or whatever
who uh you know uh
youtube song come on we gotta go there
talks about bloody sunday where fact is
fiction and tv reality i mean
bono and the crew wrote that way back
when and that still resonates with fact
is fiction and tv reality
and that's kind of where that's where we
are right now and so
it's really really difficult uh it's
it's you have to factor it into your
decision making i'm not said
and i did not do it as well but by the
same token the worst thing you do
is you do something or you respond in
the information environment that's wrong
and then you're like now you're cleaning
that up so that's
that's one of those things where i'm
like first report's always wrong
take a deep breath do some planning just
it might be 30 seconds
so all right what's going on what's next
steps okay what should we do
then you know the classic the plan does
not survive
first contact with reality true that but
that's not the point eisenhower talked
about
it's not the plan that matters it's the
planning
and even if it's 30 45 seconds you've
actually
slowed things down take a deep breath
unplug and think and so you know those
are the the key factors and then the
final one is like
wait until the last moment to make a
decision because
information keeps coming in everybody
wants to make a decision too fast and
that's where you brought back
anthony the information environment now
instead of just your subordinates or
your peers that are like you need to
make a decision you need to make a
decision now you got this
whole flood of people saying you're an
idiot
you don't know what's going on and it
takes enormous
i don't think it's courage i see i would
say discipline it takes a normal
discipline to just hold stick with your
principles
uh so it i don't know how people are
gonna do it in the future but
you brought it up young people are like
heck with this
i think there's huge opportunity out
there to break through i think that's
what
this next generation wants wants to
serve
wants to believe and they're seeing us
not you guys they're seeing me and
other people above us going wow that's
not that's just not right
i got a lot i got a lot of hope i got to
tell you yeah me too
and i think you're seeing it more
broadly where um
journalists for media companies are
leaving to go independent uh and it's
across
fields it's in finance it's in media
it's all it's all across the board
um one thing i want to ask you is that
you've had a really
long and rich career even though you
hadn't really planned it
but you mentioned kind of the importance
of your family you have a wife you have
kids
how did you balance your professional
aspirations
with making sure that you had strong
personal relationships too
not well i mean
uh it's thanks for that and i
you know special operators are by design
obsessive-compulsive i mean
and that's their greatest strength right
but it's their greatest weakness too
because they are so committed to the
mission and they're so committed to
their teammates
that that would often times
destroy their family life and that was
one of the biggest challenges
i think we faced in the last 19 years
where wars used to be like in a hundred
hour war whatever great deployed for six
months back home
you're off for next 10 years don't worry
about it we only do wars every 10 years
you're good
um you know but this last 19 years and
that's why i was just so committed to
ending this
these damn things um actually there's
only one war it's global war on
terrorism but
i guess i'll say wars uh because it's
all over the world
is that is so that was the leadership
thing
the transition from like you got to go
why because the team's going because
every every one of those people is going
to go
is it will feel guilty so i would have
to be the bad guy and i
loved it i loved the bad guy in this one
i don't mind being the bad guy to begin
with
but you're like you knew because my best
partner was the battalion surgeon our
doctor and
he climb patient client privileges you
know all that so let's not i'm not going
to give his name because he'll pro well
he's
you know but he'd like hey you need to
go talk to so-and-so
that's all i'd say and that was the cue
you go down there like what's going on
they were like everything's fine sir
everything's great i don't know
and you know then you'd have to be that
empathetic listener and you just have to
active listening you work through it and
then finally you
find out like this guy this person's in
crisis you know
and uh hey at that point you're like
you're not deploying
no i've got a deploy sir like you just
tell everybody like
hey jimmy's not deploying you guys shut
up
and they'd be like and you know the team
they all know what's going on
they're like oh thank god someone cares
you know
uh but so that was the real tragedy but
my
i was just blessed with uh my wife and i
are you know it
our solid and she raised the kids and
we'd talk about things but i always
tried to lead by example because that's
the other thing you know you're supposed
to kind of like set the example
uh but didn't do it as well as i would i
would wish but thank god
my wife raised the kids and you know
they're all semi no they're great i mean
they're in good shape so but that was
the real that's the tragedy of war right
i mean that's the tragedy of being at
war for 19 years we destroy
i mean nothing good comes out of war
nothing uh and it's just a tragic
event you have to do it sometimes i you
know that's i'm not like i'm an anti-war
everybody should be anti-war but there
are some times
where you know there's a nation we have
to go to war and but when you do it for
19 years
the cost psychologically physically
emotionally
and family relationships and so my thing
would be like
the other thing i said you will be home
for the birth of your children no i
don't care sir i don't care i don't care
about you
but your wife cares and if we're going
to keep doing this damn war
i need your wife to be partnered and
part of this
so i'm not doing it for you i'm doing it
so your wife when you need to re-enlist
she will support you i'm doing it for
the country
um one more question i have is uh we
haven't really touched on like
the mental aspect of going to war
um when i met anthony and he went to
iraq
i was like so what like how can you
sleep at night given everything you've
seen and been through and he was like
what you said he was like
i had a job i did my job and i to me
it's so interesting
from the outside seeing how people can
compartmentalize some of this stuff
how how did you do it
like when you came back yeah you're
hearing anthony i mean i'm just like a
blowhard right now but
i mean uh we everybody has a different
experience
i would i would say uh and then
for uh i gotta tell you i think mostly
it's just a desperate situation and it's
not like you're gun fighting every day
you know that anthony
you're like you only have a couple times
in a deployment where it's like okay
this is for real this is what they paid
me to do
that's the other thing you know uh for
in my situation you know volunteered
they paid for my undergraduate graduate
my wife and i she gave birth obviously
we had three kids
uh in military hospitals you know i know
you want to know how much it costs you
to have a kid in the military hospital
it's like seventeen dollars and nine
cents
because you have to pay for the meals i
don't even know why
but like oh no all the health care is
free but you have to pay for the food
and then you know when it comes down to
you're going
into combat you're like man this
this is what they paid me to do they
didn't this isn't a social welfare
program
that's not what the military is right
it's like some people think it is it's
not it
is for one thing and that's going to
fight our nation's battles
fight our nation's wars so you're like
and i mean anthony i know
i'm sure you've been there where you're
like oh man this might not work out
right i might be
dead before this day is over and you go
through the whole
i go i should say i i go through the
whole cycles of mourning
where i'm like begging god to like give
me
you know an excuse not to do this please
let me you know
break my leg uh and then you get to
acceptance and
and you just go okay i'm getting on the
helicopter i'm getting in the truck i'm
going to do this because that's what the
country paid me for
i signed a contract and you could say
like that is so
incredibly immature and how could you be
such a blind loyalist
but something's got to get you on the
helicopter and you're like man
uh so that's how i dealt with that but
you know anthony
the other thing i noticed uh the things
that bothered me the moral guilt you
know
it's it's where you knew you screwed up
and um
and those are the ones that you know
what you wake up in the night you're
like and you know you you work through
it and you process it some
you know but everybody has to deal with
it differently and regrettably that's
what we talked about when you go to war
uh you're gonna lose some people
psychologically and emotionally and it's
really tragic but that's what that's why
it's so important that the nation has a
really
serious conversation about going to war
because it destroys
people's minds and their health and
their families
and it's all right but let's just have
the discussion up front
that we're willing to do this because
people are going to
be consumed by it anthony over to you
sir
no i i think you're dead on i the only
thing i would add is uh i've told plana
and a
bunch of friends many times that uh the
biggest pacifists you'll meet
are people who've been to war because
they understand that uh
you know what it entails and the
destruction that it causes and uh
i think it's marcus latrell's got this
great speech that he gives where he
basically says listen
you know if you're a politician your job
is to be as diplomatic as possible and
do everything in your power not to send
me because when i go i'm going to bring
hell with me and you know the
u.s military is better than almost
anyone at doing it um
but you got to understand that it's not
a a you know completely
uh positive thing and so if we can
up you know want to avoid wars great if
we can end them
even better and and i think that it uh
your
your line of thinking around um our role
as this like global police uh and the
constant
obsession with going to war in a
conventional way especially right
technology is one thing but when you
start to put
you know thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of soldiers on the ground
uh it's just it's dirty right that's why
it's war
exactly you know it's like if it was
peace it would be peace
you know it's so it's like you nailed it
and i mean those are it's hey we got to
do what we got to do i got that but
let's just do it
and uh i just you know man i just
remember the waste
you know you're just like wow i mean
it's it's an amazing experience let's be
perfectly honest you're not supposed to
say that
you know mattis got in trouble like some
people need killing i'm not saying that
but some people need feeling
uh there's uh but that just like
drawn on me and like you know it's super
bowl right you've trained
you've been and you're like of course
you want to go do your job
and that was my you're just like wow
this is
nothing good's coming out of this it's
just enormously wasteful
uh so wow yeah it's just like
those are the and here's the other thing
that i've been
saying lately we brought up january 6th
and um i remind people i think if we
were having this discussion about
january 6
in 1954 we wouldn't be having this
discussion because
you know as you know only one percent of
the american public serves in uniform
right now i think about
seven percent of the population i might
be off on that are veterans
and but in 1952 you had every
probably 85 percent of congress had
served
uh in one capacity the american citizens
had served and if they didn't they know
someone who is sir
they knew the nature of the military
operations they knew the nature of war
just like you were talking
everybody knew that right and now we
have a situation
where people you know my my tagline is
you know this isn't halo
or i always say call of duty but i think
it's call of duty
you know i got corrected on that i
thought it was really funny somebody was
you called it the wrong game you totally
lost credibility with that demographic
i said i wasn't trying to get
credibility with him to begin with the
point i was trying to make
was that you know anthony you know how
military operations work
it's just not like snap and so on
january 6th you know
general order one i still remember it
from my army experience
you know in 1983 you did not get to eat
ciao
until you had memorized general order
one and you're like what the hell
i can't eat i will guard everything
within the limits of my post and quit my
post only when properly relieved
so this idea like oh poof will just take
the national guard from one side of town
and plop them down at the capitol no no
no no
if people that had military knowledge
and experience would go
you got to move people you got to
coordinate you need to backfill them in
because you just don't pull people off
their posts because
they're abandoning their posts so you
need to backfill people in all this
takes time
you move them you're moving across town
through a congested environment
and then oh gee they re
they re-equip and back to my planning
point
american mothers and fathers send their
treasure
you're we're gonna we're not just gonna
throw them into a gunfight or
it wasn't a gunfight there but into a
flipping riot
without some modicum of planning and
coordination
anthony you know oh well gee we're going
into that intersection who owns it now
metropolitan police division department
well we probably should call them and
tell them that we are going to be moving
in
from the west there's going to be a
convoy of
bad mfers coming in because you don't
want them now to think what the heck is
going on
so those are the kind of things that
really uh
concern me about where we are is this
this
of lack of familiarity with the military
and that's why i think this is an
important show
that you're doing and anthony's
experience and others experiences
i hate talking about this stuff i'm like
you know i'm like i don't want to talk
about this
it was really hard to research you
because you have never talked
i just want to move on with my life but
i also realize that there that we have
an obligation to try to educate
our citizenry citizenry so that they're
better informed
about these really serious decisions and
back to your point about
when they hear information they have a
little more context
i love that my final question for you is
now that you said you were unemployed
what is your next chapter what are you
going to do next
i started our own company it's called
i can't believe you did that because i
was going to send you a note go hey can
i give a shout out
uh what i'm doing next so thanks for
doing that tonight of course i don't
know how these things work whether
that's how it works i'm curious
set up a we're sending setting up our
own company here in dc it's called
boundary channel partners boundary
channel is the road
that connects national airport the
pentagon
to northern virginia and then then gets
you to all the bridges and
also in the potomac river there's a
boundary channel which is this beautiful
so we call it connecting the world but
it's not going to be your classic you
know
lobbying influence peddling company like
most people do here they leave
government and like
oh yeah i'll get you a meeting with
so-and-so or a phone number we're not
doing that what we really want to do
is we so the team stupid
stupid smart people and we know
government but more importantly we know
international affairs so what we're
trying to do
is we're trying to we don't want to go
into government space
like we're over that we want to support
commercial entities
that might not have the mass to have a
strategic planning team
or a business development team for
international stuff because we know
everybody like a good country been there
or i know somebody's been there
so what we want to do and our real thing
is mid-cap we don't want
northrop grumman's not going to hire us
because you heard my pitch about like
we're going the wrong road we're going
down the wrong road
on this so my thing and our team's thing
is uh to look at uh companies that have
innovative stuff that want to scale and
you know hey give us a call
and we'll we'll give you some risk
assessment we'll give you some ideas you
might decide like
like now that's or if we don't know
we're not going to keep taking money
from your like wrong person call them
so we're doing that i'm also writing a
book
about coming up that's a whole new
experience lifelong
learner well somebody offered like would
you write a book i'm like sure if you
can sell it so we're in the process of
doing that now
uh for the purpose of trying to educate
the american people but it's going to be
more forward leaning and the things that
we talked about
you know china i got one of my plugs is
here's the other one i'm sorry
now i'm on my soapbox
i got to tell you i i've done my survey
of the young generation my kids
generation
and we have got to put expand universal
service
and i'm not talking about just like oh
you got to go in the army no no no no no
freaking environmental healthcare
schools
infrastructure have an overseas
component if you want to go carry if you
want to join the military that's fine
too
18 months do that and then we you're
lined up
almost like the gi bill where you'll
have opportunities for college or to
start your own business
so those are the things that i'm taking
on uh because
i'm not giving up in america yet it's
it's it we got problems right now we
know that but i'm not i'm
be embarrassing and my friends and
family would just
uh never be able to tolerate me if i
just walked away from the thing so i'm
i'm with you guys that's why i think
it's really important that
what you're doing and having these
conversations thank you so much chris
this was
excellent i learned a lot and uh
well we'll do it again hopefully all
right good luck if you need anything let
me know